il ya deux siècles de privilèges des
grandes villes et la métropolisation
parce que contrairement à ce que mon
collègue en dire des métropoles existe
depuis belle lurette
c'est par un label d'une réforme
territoriale qui entérine un processus
de très longue haleine qui est en fait
la démesure urbaine la grandeur urbaine
et deuxième élément je vivre à la
sagacité tout le monde sait que ce
produit historique de la grandeur
urbaine ça s'appelle du capitalisme
voilà c'est quelque chose qui renvoient
à des intérêts économiques à
l'employabilité l'offre d'activités à la
concentration du capital dans des
endroits et ça s'est fait au détriment
des périphéries et des campagnes
voilà les métropoles on mettra au
colisée l'entièreté des espaces y
compris les espaces dits de nature qui
sont en fait une agriculture intensive
conventionnelle et qui produisent
toujours plus toujours plus toujours
plus pour alimenter les polarités
urbaines qui ne cesse de grossir
donc après on peut s'étonner qu'il ya
des mouvements de révolte de rebellions
on parlait de gilet jaune ya deux
secondes avec des propos peu amènes
peut-être moi je ne serai pas de cette
culture là ce sont les périphéries il
commence un peu à se poser la question
de l'égalité du traitement et de la
justice qui se joue derrière
[Musique]